[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez rentrer dans mon bureau
monsieur jo va nous avons plusieurs cas
dans un peu moins de deux semaines ils
seront sur scène comme chaque mardi les
comédiens de la troupe en chantier
répète la jeune compagnie est lancée en
2014 son créateur c'est lui pierre henry
gates
j'avais une pièce qui était dans un
tiroir depuis quelques années ils
s'appellent les fantômes de l'écrivain
je n'allais pas de projet avec pour la
montée en fait et c'est quand j'ai donné
des cours de théâtre à la compagnie
versailles soleil j'avais un vivier de
comédien dans ses cours là ça m'est venu
d'un coup j'ai envoyé des mails en
disant voilà si je reprends la pièce cet
été déclaré cris est ce que ça vous
intéresse delajoux et qu'on monte une
troupe ça sera plus sous forme de coups
etc je ne suis pas lassé petite réaction
par rapport à l'état c'est ok
prendre des bus pour relancer deux ans
plus tard ils sont quatorze comédiens
amateurs et jouent des créations de la
comédie dramatique de l'humour noir de
pièces sorties de l'imagination du
metteur en scène je préfère monter mes
propres projets parce que j'ai ma
conception
j'ai pas me demander quelles sont les
intentions de l'auteur puisque ben voilà
c'est moi du coup là si je mettais du
molière au lift expire j'aurai plus de
mal à défendre les propos de l'auteur je
pense qu'ils ce qui m'a beaucoup plu
c'est effectivement de
participer à une pièce qui était une
création et je trouve que c'est toujours
intéressant
de s'impliquer dans une dans une
création parce que on donne naissance un
personnage une jeune troupe qui a déjà
joué à deux reprises lors du mois
molière et qui parcourt les scènes d'île
de france